[Música]
i
les gustaría emprender
vamos a no le gustaría aprender ahora si
este
un día estábamos en una pequeña reunión
y aparece aparece un chico que se llama
matías está en la foto de remera
amarilla lo bien identificado no es de
boca claro por las dudas y nos muestra
que hacía videojuegos les tenía aprendió
en su casa ustedes saben hoy en día el
conocimiento está al alcance de todos
quien no entra en google quien no entra
en otra plataforma y busca la
información que necesita puede aprender
se puede especializar calculo que cuando
le hará una tarea ustedes van a google
primero y el libro medio que están
olvidando o no
este 4 matías tenía un desafío que era
quiero hacer un videojuego y quiero
vivir de eso es decir quiero hacer lo
que me gusta y quiero que lo que me
gusta me genere ingresos que me permitan
vivir que estimo yo que es lo que todos
ustedes quieren hay dos formas de
encarar esto no una forma es trabajar
para alguien y que te digan que tienes
que hacer y otra forma es hago lo que me
gusta hago lo que quiero y en base a eso
vivo pero a veces donde nosotros tenemos
diferentes diferentes miedos vemos
distintos obstáculos no es sencillo pero
tampoco es imposible y es eso lo
importante que queremos resaltar hoy
matías nos muestra eso
y esta foto que bien acaba bueno
trajimos a la asociación argentina de
videojuegos es decir bueno acá tenemos
talento en la provincia queremos que los
los capaciten queremos que ellos se
puedan especializar y así como matías
digo yo tenemos el 40 por ciento de la
población menor de 18 años debe haber
muchísimos chicos más quizás hay alguno
acá que le guste y desarrollo de
videojuegos entonces en base a eso
por la culpa de matías creamos un curso
que te enseñe a programar y a
desarrollar videojuegos en el cual
descubrimos en base a este desarrollo
que en la provincia de misiones habían
muchísimos chicos que hacían pequeños
desarrollos en su casa pero que no
hacían del desarrollo un negocio y
muchas veces cuesta aplicar esto que yo
sé eso que me gusta a cómo generar esos
ingresos recién escuchamos a matías
la tiene muy en claro cuál es su
horizonte cómo empezó lo acabo de contar
pero en este caso faltaba eso faltaba
cerrar eso y faltaba mucha capacitación
para que lo que yo hago sea lo mejor
entonces de esta forma es hicimos el
curso trajimos gente de cartoon network
e capacita a los chicos y en base a eso
hoy matías pudo desarrollar su juego
gracias a aquí está el polo tic es un
polo tecnológico y de desarrollo de
innovación de nuevas tecnologías que
capacitamos justamente donde vemos en lo
que vemos que haga falta capacitar para
nuestros jóvenes hoy tenemos este este
curso tenemos muchísimos más
y lo importante es resaltar en este tipo
de encuentro es el valor de emprender el
valor de hacer lo que queremos hacerlo
bien y en base a eso poder levantarnos
todas las mañanas y ustedes saben que
hay una motivación más grande que todos
que es hacer lo que nos gusta y es
nuestra voluntad la que nos lleva a día
a día a levantarnos
y llegar a lograrlo ustedes se levantan
contentos y con ganas para ir al colegio
es bueno
este es muy importante que esa
motivación es la que nos mueve día a día
imagínense ustedes terminan en el
colegio el año que viene seguramente
algunos sabrán que estudiar otros no
sabrán qué estudiar pero es eso que
ustedes elijan lo que le va a motivar
día a día decía son las seis de la
mañana me tengo que levantar tengo que
irme
a la facultad tengo que irme al trabajo
tengo que ir a emprender es decir tengo
que ir hacer lo que a mí me gusta y en
base a eso vivo creamos una marca que es
fabricado en el polo tic misiones para
que en el caso de matías que hizo su
desarrollo nosotros lo estamos ayudando
y hay 40 chicos más igual que él que
gracias a que hicimos esto se sumaron y
vinieron a estar con nosotros
pero no todo es tecnología hoy en día no
no hay por qué ser una obligación que a
ustedes les guste emprender en materia
tecnología después está el caso de
gonzalo gonzalo no sé si alguna vez
escucharon hablar de la canasta
escucharon usarlo bien un día y nos dice
me dice lucas quiero vender ropa para
bebés
y porque no sé pero hay muchos bebés
boda por la calle y sí o sí cruzadas
muchos chicos tiene que ser un negocio
pero tener esa experiencia que averigua
este y no nada pero vi eso y bueno la
poca plata que tengo quiero dedicarla a
comprar ropa para bebé y revenderla y
vos que sabes hacer y yo sé cocinar mes
a bien es bueno libre porque no no ves
que poder desarrollar dentro de tus
conocimientos por ahí tenés una idea
inicio de una vida vi un producto que
era como una empanada abierta que se
llama canastita la bien buenos aires y
la verdad que eso me gustó y visité
tiradas por ese lado que es lo que vos
sabes hacer lo que vamos te gusta
y bueno en base a eso
a la canasta la canasta este desarrollo
en unos productos este es uno de ellos
este al cual le aplica un valor es decir
todos saben que hay una empanada de
jamón y queso hay una empanada de carne
pero una canastita gourmet en una
canasta de cordero una canastita de
rúcula y parmesano ya es un producto
diferencial es un producto que agrega
valor también y que cautiva a un cierto
público que cuando la prueba este te
enamora sinceramente te enamoras
entonces hoy gonzalo tiene un negocio
muy exitoso en la ciudad de posadas
empezó solo usted dice en la ayuda de
los padres no las llevar a los amigos y
cappa con algún consejo
la mujer le ayude yo no sólo le di el
interrogante de por qué iba a vender
ropa para bebé y no iba a hacer lo que
le gustaba que era cocinar
empezamos así empezó con un local
chiquitito hoy ya tiene un hijo el hijo
creció ahí adentro
se pudieron comprar más equipamiento y
hoy tienen la canasta que es un negocio
exitoso en las ciudades posadas es muy
importante resaltar estos dos casos son
pequeños casos de llamémosle de éxito
pero cuando hablamos que alguien tiene
éxito no es porque es millonario ni se
baja de un mercedes benz este y bien
acaba la charla es exitoso porque hizo
lo que le gusta tiene la motivación
cautiva este en el día a día y en hacer
lo que lo que tiene ganas lo que tiene
ganas de hacer eso es posible y está al
alcance de todos ustedes en la provincia
de misiones es una provincia es una
provincia hacedora es una provincia
makers habrán escuchado el término
muchas veces ustedes saben que desde el
estado desde la innovación están todas
las herramientas para que hoy puedan
emprender y hacer lo que ustedes éste lo
que ustedes más les guste
tenemos el único lugar en el país donde
aquel que quiere emprender y no tiene
los recursos para hacerlo no sólo hay
una incubadora que te va
a que tu idea sea realidad y sea un
negocio si no también te va a ayudar con
financiamiento a que vos lo puedas
lograr y con unas condiciones que no
existen en otra parte del mundo
aprovechen chicos emprendan ahora le
hago le hago una pregunta mañana ahora
emprender
muchas gracias
[Música]